[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh damn and they told me take off your
jacket
I said babe man yo man never be hot hey
what's up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime outpour and I really hope you
enjoyed this quick big Shaq sans not hot
skit we make this type of parody content
here on the channel once in a while not
too long ago we made an anime parody of
its everyday bro called it's anime bro
and of course we make a lot of Dragon
Ball super content right here on the
channel so if you are new consider
subscribing for more I think that big
Shaq narrating the Goku vs. jiren fight
was almost as good as my boy NOx Tahu
sarcastic commentary I want to give a
big shout out to the guys at anime
balls-deep for giving me the idea to
make something like this by throwing in
some big shock in their latest kefla
video I will leave a link to that video
in the description be sure to check it
out and I'll also leave a link to NOx
Taku sarcastic commentary also thank you
to ANBU from our discord server for
linking me another parody of man's nod
that also inspired me to make this and
last but not least my brother goes and
really jumped on this idea and made the
execution happen so kudos to him if
you have other ideas for skits that you
would like us to do you can follow us on
twitter at anime uproar and let us know
as always thank you so much for watching
and until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]